adam many thanks uh this is to do with
uh cricket and specifically essex uh
county cricket club we have heard in the
past few minutes that uh john farah has
resigned with immediate effect as chair
of the county cricket club now this
follows a historic allegation of racist
language being used by him at a board
meeting in
2017 we don't know the exact details
what we do know is mr farah stepped down
following a board meeting last night
essex county cricket club has put out a
statement saying it does not tolerate
discrimination of any kind and will
immediately consider further steps the
club must take now uh mr farah himself
uh strongly denies the incident but the
club is now going to review uh why it
was not fully and independently
investigated at the time ethics has a
relatively newly appointed chief
executive john stevenson who has said
there is no place for discrimination of
any kind at essex county cricket club of
course follows the row uh concerning
yorkshire and we know that the chief
executive mark arthur uh resigned
yesterday from there but this is john
farah
who has quit with immediate effect as
the chair of essex county cricket club
following a historical allegation of
racist language used by him at a board
meeting in 2017.